I'm Spartacus
I know what you're thinking more remotes
so here we go to resent her next Awards
run away to Buenos Aires Argentina I'm
waiting to host our show there after a
7,000 mile I've got to dance
I am music I have I'm dancing an up
dancer after 7,000 mile flight from
Hollywood is a man who brought the 10
commandments down from Mount Sinai
parted the Red Sea painted the Sistine
Chapel this guy can't hold a job but
ladies and gentlemen go with me on this
please he won both the chariot race and
an Academy Award his performance in Ben
Hur
ladies and gentlemen Charlton Heston
muchas gracias when it's not just a
follows that long flight from Hollywood
was well worthwhile
I met a great actress here una from a
priest gig and not only speak Spanish a
lot better than I do but if she's a
whole lot prettier she's the star of the
official story the first Argentine film
to win an Academy Award which she
herself won as Best Supporting Actress
in the film Gabi miss Norma van bro
do we need some horses at last oh you've
been keeping all those Commandments then
huh here in Argentina are you man
this is the Contra beautiful man
beautiful women and beautiful wine
that's three Commandments gone right
there and now we also have the beautiful
academy awards coming to you from the
sold and beautiful theater theatrical
only it is one
I want to say this is one of the most
beautiful theaters I have ever seen
where we are honored tonight by the
presence of the director of this
magnificent house who in 1975 directed
the first Argentine film nominated for
an Academy Award for Best Foreign Film
Serena
you know
it's it's almost 2 o'clock in the
morning here in Buenos Aires I think
it's time we got down to work
Norma you begin mr. commandant
absolutamente okay why not
the nominees for Best Documentary short
subjects are fine food fine pastries
open six to nine David Peterson producer
the Johnstown Flood Charles Guggenheim
producer
yad vashem preserved in the past to
ensure the future ray error fox producer
and now the man from Price Waterhouse
and the Oscar goes to the Johnstown
Flood Charles Guggenheim producer
I'm a very lucky man thank God no I
didn't make films I want to thank and to
honor the people of Johnstown
Pennsylvania who endured probably
America's greatest disaster
and for those who saved me from one my
cameraman parish Roland Kathy shields my
editor the Michael bacon who wrote the
music - Donna Deveraux - Gwen Williams
and especially to my wife and to the
greatest Associate Producer who ever
held to produce his hand my daughter
Grace thanks to the Academy for
supporting everything
now let's go back where Carlton and I
are gonna do a full-contact Lambada this
is gonna be amazing
come on Billy you know I can't dance the
Mambo I can't even finish it teach me as
a moviegoer though I take special
pleasure in documentary features they
have a an importance that deserves the
widest audience and tonight we honor the
best of these Norma the nominees for
documentary features our Adam Clayton
Powell which are catered and Van Smith
producers
common threads stories from the quilt
Robert Epstein and Bill couturier
producers
crack us a County under siege
Vince dipper Co and William guten tag
producers fellow mankind ly nerd and
Betsy Broyles Breyer producers super
chief the life and legacy of Earl Warren
Judith Leonard and Bill Jersey producers
and the Oscar goes to common fleets toys
from the kilt Robert Epstein and bigotry
producers
the thrill my co-producers Jeffrey
Friedman bill Kotori and I would like to
thank our very dedicated crew our brave
storytellers who appeared in the film
Bobby McFerrin for his beautiful score
Cleve Jones and everyone who made the
names project AIDS quilt Elizabeth
Taylor for her support and for her
heroic efforts in fighting AIDS and to
all those fighting AIDS
especially the gay and lesbian community
thank you for leading the nation with
courage and dignity and urgency mayor
government soon follow sometimes those
of us who make documentaries can feel
that Hollywood doesn't have a heart our
films proof that it did Sandy Gallin
Howard Rosenman Kell balm all the people
at sand dollar home box office CAA and
especially sis Wilson this is for you
and Kathy for telling me you got to make
a film on the quilt honey you were right
thank you
let's make sure it gets his Tallis back